I've been doing coffee enemas nearly every day, rife treatments, supplements, including binders.
I previously expelled a lot of liver flukes. I went a while not seeing anything, but now I'm
expelled in worms. How do I know if I got all these parasites up? Well, there isn't, like I've
always said, there isn't any perfect labs out there, but doing a comprehensive stool analysis test
might be an order. I don't know that you would need to do that. I mean, if you're able to see that
you're expelled in parasites, I think I would just keep on track of what you're doing and keep
track of, you know, trying to view them. I know that's kind of a little test for a lot of people
like you listening, but you're trying to get rid of parasites. You want to get rid of parasites,
and if you can see them, know that you're expelled in all the better. Comprehensive
stool analysis tests, I think they're about three, four hundred dollars, and they're certainly not
perfect. Like any other test, I've had people that know they have parasites at that, like this stool
parasite test comes back negative. Because solely measuring, you know, a small portion of your stool
at that specific time and if things could get missed. So I would just stay the course. That's all
what I would do. I would just stay what you're doing.